and first drive obviously you're moving
the ball big play on the first down
first play of the game
uh and then you know obviously you know
following the exchange there
it was uh frustrating but uh
look we
we know what type of
offense we've had this year has been
pretty efficient the only thing that's
been stopping us for the most part has
been ourselves and
not converting third downs and turned
the ball over today obviously uh hurt us
really bad we're disappointed
um you know we don't do a lot of the uh
you know silver lining losses
it's about uh real critiques and
we'll get in the film room tomorrow
we'll look at it we'll be
you know really thorough in in our
critiques of ourselves
give credit to our opponent it's good
defense you know i feel like we moved
the ball you know great in first half
obviously the third quarter was two
three and outs it wasn't great
but when he had to have it there at the
end of the game you know move the ball
down in scoring position and
and tied it up timmy finally won a coin
toss got the ball over time and
you know obviously you know what
happened in the end so disappointing for
sure a good chance for us to uh
you know take a three-game lead in
division but uh
we're two games up got a big game coming
up against chicago
[Music]
[Music]
offensively from an offensive standpoint
you're going gosh we shouldn't be in
this situation we got to finish it we
can't put our defense in this mode but
yeah so you certainly have those
thoughts but at the same time you're uh
you're fired up i mean you're believing
that the defense is going to get a stop
and they did and yes did they go 80
yards and get a field goal they did but
they didn't end the game and they
kept us alive and then they went out
there and got to take away
phillip rivers after the 34-31
victory by the colts over the packers
my favorite stat of the weekend this
came from espn stats and information
aaron rodgers against every team in the
nfl except the colts
the packers 95 and 2
when leading by 14 or more points
against the cults 1-2 when leading by 14
or more points it happened back in 2012
when andrew luck was a rookie the last
time the packers were in indianapolis he
quite possibly has never won in
indianapolis that'd be right yeah aaron
rodgers so uh and it looked it's another
one of those it looked like it was going
to be easy looked like it was going to
be easy and then the colts found the gas
pedal and they they made it compelling
and they ultimately turned it into a
victory to keep pace with the titans
setting up next week's showdown in
indianapolis tennessee at the colts for
possibly at the end of the day the
division championship yeah well i mean
the colts have a lot of things to like
about their football team as we know and
we know they've messed up some games and
rivers has had a few choppy moments
throughout the year but i think this
this and then beating the tennessee
titans you know on thursday night last
week should show everybody like the
colts are here
they're real you know how real they are
i don't know there's still a little work
in progress but anybody watching that
game yesterday you come away going whoa
i mean first off to shut down aaron
rodgers and company three points in the
whole second half i mean just three and
out three and out three now that's how
it started the second half you know and
and then there we saw the packers flaws
on the defensive side of the ball and
once again you know they just slowly get
worn down worn down worn down and then
yeah there was a self-inflicted mistakes
by the packers but colts that defense
has moments of being unbelievably
dominant and we saw that yesterday and
if rivers in that run game can be
something man the colts i mean there's a
lot to like about their team and they're
they're still going to be a player in
the afc as we're seeing here
packers defense taking a lot of
criticism i looked at twitter at one
point last night and i saw mike pettin
trending and not for good reasons
packers fans up in arms about the way
the defense collapsed but you know if
your offense continues to fire on all
cylinders a lead turns into a blowout
and so i think it's both sides of the
board have to be blamed for this
collapse it's not just the defense
definitely giving up a bunch of points
when the offense is showing that it's
getting it done and all of a sudden it's
not getting it done and it can't get it
done puts more pressure on the defense
yeah no doubt no doubt there's you're
right the defense they were on the field
too much because the offense at least
couldn't even get first downs chew up
the clock give them a little rest do
something
uh but either way that was an impressive
win by the colts hanging in there and
making some clutch plays when they
needed to to win the game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports